-You talk a lot about
your family in previous show,
and your mom actually hid
some of your history from you.
Is that true?
-Yeah, you know.
I mean, our history,
Latin people,
we were there during
the American Revolution,
the Civil War, and it´s not in
textbooks, movies or anything.
And my mom was kind of like
that with my father´s history
because he abandoned our asses.
Pardon me. Excuse me,
but I had to go there.
-Excuse him, by the way.
-Thank you.
-You´re allowed
to say that, yeah.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
-How much do you charge
for 45 minutes.
[ Laughter ]
A lot less than my real
therapist charges,
that´s for sure.
-Do you match your therapist
couch when you go there?
Do you like where the...?
-I have always had a problem
blending in.
[ Laughter ]
-Urban camo.
Talk show camo.
-So she hid stuff
about your --
-With my dad, she would be like,
"John, I never wanted
to bad mouth your father.
No, because then it would
ruin the moment
When you figured it out
by yourself."
[ Laughter ]
Gotta love that woman.
-That´s very nice.
You have an aversion...
Tell me about a Thanksgiving
with your family.
What´s that like?
-Well, you know,
everybody´s always
talking over each other,
like three conversations,
three threads and everybody´s
following it.
I have a hard time
with Thanksgiving,
because I feel like a traitor
when I sit down
because ever since I was a
little boy, man, I always wished
there had been some wizened
woman who said to her people
before the pilgrims sat down,
"Don´t feed them!
If you feed them,
they´ll never leave!"
[ Laughter ]
And that food
must have been that good,
not like my mom´s cooking.
-Not good?
-The pilgrims
would have swam back
without the goddamn Mayflower,
seriously.
My mom´s been serving
leftovers for 50 years.
To this day, no one´s ever found
the original meal.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously,
I´m not making this up.
-Um...
Over the course of you career,
actors obviously have to make
a lot of choices.
-Yeah.
-Some great. Some...
-Not so great.
-I did not realize...
I knew you had been in the
"Super Mario Bros." movie.
-Yeah. Shh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I´m proud of it.
I´m proud of it now.
-Was it With Bob Hoskins?
-Yes, and Dennis Hopper.
-And Dennis Hopper.
-The late Dennis Hopper.
My acting, I think,
got rid of them, too.
-Oh, no. I don´t think so.
But those are two guys, of
course you would do that movie
But you turned down a role
in the film "Philadelphia"...
Yes.
-to do "Super Mario Bros."
-I was supposed to be
Tom Hanks´ lover,
but I didn´t think he was good
looking enough for me.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
-I wanted, like Kevin Costner
or Denzel Washington.
So I turned it down
for "Super Mario Bros.",
and then, of course,
they all won Oscars
and I won a the "John,
how can you be stupid award?"
for my wife.
-Yeah.
"Mario Bros." didn´t win
any Oscars. Nominated?
-Um, not so much.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe a Raspberry.
-I think they´ll make up for it.
I think it will eventually be
a recognized film.
-Right, as the first video game
ever made into a movie.
-Right. Now, those things
come out once a month.
So you were a trail blazer.
-I was a pioneer.
-Thanks so much for being here.